merci à mme anne charrier d'être avec
nous quels sont les enjeux stratégiques
immédiats de vladimir poutine marioupol
évidemment c'est la ville dont on est en
train de parler beaucoup aujourd'hui
parce qu'elle est sur la mer d'azov
parce que c'est un port parce que ça
fait partie de sa continuité avec le
donbass s'il veut récupérer cette zone
là et que pour lui ce n'est pas quelque
chose qui est négociable
autant peut s'interroger sur kiev autant
on peut s'interroger sur odessa kharkiv
semble effectivement être une zone de
combat important pour lui mais
éventuellement le il peut se passer de
kharkiv autant marioupol reste
fondamentalement son objectif en ce
moment d'où le fait qu'on a clairement
j'allais dire une situation de guerre à
la russe où on encercle pour évidemment
couper la population de
l'approvisionnement en eau et en
nourriture
ce qui est classique d'un siège de
l'électricité parce que ce non seulement
vous avez froid mais en plus du coup
vous ne pouvez pas renvoyer des images
vous ne pouvez plus communiquer avec
l'extérieur et vous avez des
bombardements jusqu'à ce que vous
puissiez à rentrer mais marioupol monde
la lumière poutine n'y renoncera pas
cette idée hier de faire appel à des
volontaires soit disant syrien ça dit
quoi sur le régime et les difficultés de
l'armée russe qui est quand même
numériquement et militairement et
techniquement très supérieur à l'armée
et craignant ça veut dire en fait que la
guerre ne s'est pas passé comme prévu
pour vladimir poutine et ça ça fait
partie aussi de la guerre j'allais dire
malheureusement vous avez toujours des
plans qui sont préconisées au départ et
puis ensuite vous les adapter au fur et
à mesure des campagnes et ça veut dire
simplement que l'idée de durcir la
guerre n'est pas du tout quelque chose
qui est négligée par la russie et
qu'aujourd'hui on a vu qu'il y avait
quand même un moment donné la voie de la
diplomatie qui était entendu on a bien
vu que tous étaient un peu arrêté ces
derniers jours au moment où il y avait
le sommet de versailles au moment où les
deux ministres des affaires étrangères
étaient en train de discuter à antalya
c'est la première fois qu'il soyez qui
discutaient ça voulait dire beaucoup
donc il faut pas croire du tout que
moscou n'y est pas sensible et que
vladimir poutine n'est pas en train de
regarder quel est le bon moment où il va
falloir qu'ils arrêtent mais en
attendant il prépare aussi une guerre
beaucoup plus classique qui est de dire
si je dois demain aller plus loin dans
ces cas là il faudra que j'aie des
renforts qui viennent j'aurai des
renforts de l'armée qu'on vend lionel
j'amènerai plus d'hommes c'est ce qu'on
avait vu en tchétchénie 94 passé d'homme
99 désarmé beaucoup plus opérationnels
du côté de la russie est donc jamais un
aussi des combattants étrangers alors
les combattants étrangers l'avantagent 6
et les syriens c'est que ce sont des
mercenaires c'est que ce sont des gens
sans foi ni loi qui savent combattre
donc ils pourront venir effectivement
épauler les russes c'est un peu la même
image qu'on avait des tchétchènes par
exemple en revanche ce qui veut dire
qu'il est très grave c'est que dès qu'on
se retrouve sur ce terrain d'opération
et de guerre les ukrainiens feront de
même et de la même manière qu'on a
besoin de les réarmer la même manière
ils feront appel aux milices qui seront
elles aussi fait de mercenaires de gens
les plus durs alors on parle toujours
des ministres d'azov qui sont les
milices emblématique que parce qu'elles
portent l'insigne nazis mais dans ces
cas là viendront d'europe tous les néo
nazis qui ont besoin aussi d'aller
casser quelque part du russe est d'aller
casser du combattant plus des islamistes
qui peuvent venir aussi sans filtreront
dans les deux camps donc ça fait partie
des choses qui sont complexes à gérer et
qui font qu'on est tous en train
d'attendre que l'hymne solutions de paie
un peu qui se dessine mais si on va vers
une guerre qu'ils se rassurent les
garçons plusieurs mois ça sera
effectivement compliquée et les
négociations réel risque de ne pas
s'ouvrir avant plusieurs semaines
effectivement alors on est tout le temps
en train de guetter les petits mots qui
font dire que l'un et l'autre ont
compris que ce soit entre poutine et
zelensky le moment où justement ils
pourront lâcher parce que l'un et
l'autre auront quelque chose à négocier
voilà merci beaucoup armés charrier pour
votre analyse merci à vous